how does a cashback debit card work and
where's the money coming from comes from
transaction fees Merchant fees they can
then take part of that fee and give it
back to you to get you to use the debit
card more because they make money when
you use your debit card they make
transaction fees not off of you but off
of the merchant that you are buying from
same thing's true with credit card by
the way yeah uh credit card pays the
exact same fees as a matter of fact yeah
uh Merchant fees are exactly the same we
don't pay less or more because it's a
debit card the the credit card companies
don't just make money on the interest MH
on your debt they also make money on the
transaction fees